[Music]
hi everyone welcome to day two of next
the afternoon that is my name is Megan
O'Keefe just to make sure you're in the
right place this is hybrid 201 sto in
production day two traffic routing
alright welcome great so I'm here today
my name is Megan hello I'm here today to
talk to you all about how to manage
traffic in production with SEO in 40
minutes just a bit about me I am a
developer programs engineer at Google
cloud I my job is to work closely with
our engineering and product teams here
at Google to make sure that you the
users have the best experience possible
with our technologies specifically I
work on kubernetes and
sto in my previous role I was working as
an engineer doing multi cluster
kubernetes at the edge of the network so
service mesh is super excited exciting
for me and I'm so excited to be here
today and thank you so much to everyone
joining here live and on the livestream
as well so raise your hand if you know
what SEO is whoo okay raise your hand if
you have installed this CEO and used it
awesome love but fewer hands raise your
hand if you're running sto in production
oh my gosh this is many more hands than
I expected this is very exciting
I am here today to kind of go beyond the
hello world of ischium there's a lot of
intro content out there and I'm here to
throat show through demos and through
concepts how to actually do things with
this video so let's get right into it
I've divided up this talk into four
parts first I just want to make sure
we're all on the same page about what
SDO is and how it works
because of time reasons I wish I could
cover things like multi cluster sto and
mesh expansion with VMs for the purposes
of this talk we are here today to talk
about sto running on one kubernetes
cluster plain old open source sto the
rest of the talk will dive into demos
about traffic rules inside of a cluster
so east-west traffic and then the latter
part of the talk will focus on
ingress traffic in and egress traffic
out so how does this do work you may
have heard of this concept of a service
mesh right there are many definitions of
service mesh this is one picture all of
your workloads running on the platform
such as kubernetes the idea behind the
service mesh is it is a common substrate
lives on top of your workloads does not
modify them and through something like a
set of proxies allows you the operator
to manage network interactions in a very
consistent way this is what a service
Besh is sto is one implementation of
this paradigm there are multiple
open-source service mesh tools out there
SDO is one was created a few years ago
by Google and in partnership with
companies such as IBM and Red Hat it is
fully open source but I think that this
definition sort of under sells what SEO
is really I think what is do actually is
is it's a platform and you're like oh my
gosh no not another platform right
kubernetes is a platform but I really do
think that SCO is a platform right it
lives on top of kubernetes exposes a set
of api's for you to do some very
powerful things raise your hand if
you've heard of K native yeah so K
native is this amazing open source
server list platform that uses sto works
on top of isseo to do really cool stuff
with simple serverless functions on
kubernetes that's super cool just one
example of how you can build on top of
this deal so I wanted to say that
outright how does it work and I'm sorry
if this is sort of review for you but
the way SEO works is through a set of
sidecar proxies so this is the data
plane so in this example we have one
kubernetes cluster a set of pods those
are the gray boxes and inside each pod
we have two containers so remember in
kubernetes that a pod can contain one or
more containers and the thing about a
pod in kubernetes
is that they share the same Linux
network interface what this means is
that containers in the same pod can talk
to each other over localhost
so this is how the magic of Asiya works
and what
happens is you use SEO to inject proxies
into your workloads and then all
subsequent traffic inbound and outbound
goes through those proxies and you're
like okay so what like proxy is great
well this is what sto does sto
configures these proxies using rules
that you give it to do very customizable
things with envoy and I want to go back
to just mention that those pink hexagons
what exactly is that proxy it is the
Envoy proxy so this is an open source
layer 7 high-performance proxy written
in C++ SEO is not the only service mesh
tool that uses envoy you can use envoy
on your own some of you might even have
written the control plane that
configures envoy proxies sto that is the
job of this do one key thing to note
here right is that sto installs its API
on kubernetes as CR DS CR d stands for
custom resource definition so what this
means is that you can interact with your
sto policies and your rules and all of
that using coops ETL using kubernetes
native tooling and this becomes relevant
when you're trying to do things like
continuous deployment for SEO resources
and you want a good way to do it put it
all together we have the full estilo
architecture at the top we have the data
plane at the bottom we have the control
plane the key thing to note here is that
the Envoy sidecars can handle multiple
different types of traffic so remember
so this is layer 7 so we're talking HTTP
GRP see that layer the application layer
that is to say and it's all running in
kubernetes again you can run workloads
and VMs sto can't handle it but
unfortunately don't have the time today
I'm here today mostly to talk about
configuring pilots SCO has multiple
control plane components so we have
galley for config ingestion we have said
it'll for cert management for M TLS and
we have mixer for telemetry these are
all crucial components for SCO mainly
the way that you configure traffic is
indirectly through pilot and pilot
pushes your config your traffic rules
down to the Envoy proxies
in the form of filters so you the
operator are never interacting directly
with these proxies you talk to us you
the control plane and you might be kind
of wondering like okay like so what
what's the actual added value of taking
on a piece of complexity such as SEO
right it's not the world's most easy
thing to just deploy it it's what does
it get you a whole lot for traffic
management so one just basic visibility
into which micro Service is calling
which you might have experienced this
yourself if you were if you're trying to
decouple a monolith into micro services
introduces a whole bunch of problems
such as all of a sudden you have these
services making Network calls to each
other that maybe they weren't doing
before traffic inspection so taking
individual requests and making decisions
based on things like HTTP headers I'm
going to demo this in just a moment
granular percentage based routing so the
thing about a kubernetes service plain
old service is that you are limited by
your workload scaling and what I mean by
this is say you have a kubernetes
service and behind that sits a bunch of
pods and you want to do a canary
deployment and you have let's say one
pod per deployment the best you could do
is 5050 there would be no way in
kubernetes plane to just say I want 1%
of traffic to go to that new canary
version so I could roll back really
quickly if something goes wrong so
there's that automation this is I think
a really really key thing if you take
away anything from this talk and I hope
it's this because sto exposes api's that
you can add yeah moles to and use all of
the tooling that you would be using with
plain old kubernetes you can do an
essential automation that you could not
do before so I'm talking like turn on em
TLS end-to-end encryption for your
entire mesh with a single rule that's
pretty amazing right
and finally decouple the network from
your application code what this means is
that if you're moving to micro services
you might have multiple programming
languages now you might have a lot of
services to deal with a lot of teams
owning these services with this do you
no longer have to have your developers
think about things like firewall rules
or
we try logic the idea of sto is to take
all of that Network logic and to put it
in the hands of the operators so that
you can manage it in a unified way and I
know this is kind of a sort of maybe a
mental shift from thinking about the way
we do these things and it's incremental
and I'll mention that at the end as well
okay that is how SEO works in a very
small nutshell what I'm going to do now
is get into the fun part the demos
traffic rules so how do you tell is CEO
to do things with the sidecar proxies
this is the question right
sto exposes a traffic API it exposes
multiple objects here are four today
we'll mainly just be talking about these
the first is a destination rule
what's a destination rule it is a way to
group a service into subsets which is
just a long version of saying you can
take a kubernetes service and partition
it however you want so in this example
I'm about to show doing a partition
based on versions but you could have
something like here's my prod front-end
and here's my build front-end you could
do that and this destination will backs
a virtual service and this is really the
key traffic rule API object in a co that
you should that you should know a
virtual service is the way that you list
rules so in this example here this yamo
I am going to do a traffic splitting
demo in which I canary or Bluegreen is
really the operator of a second version
of my front-end micro service and I'm
going to direct 10% of traffic to it
this is sort of the hello world of Sto
so I apologize if you've seen this a
million times but just to kind of get
our feet wet here it's gonna be the
first demo I show so yeah so what's the
value of doing this granular percentage
based routing that is steel lets you do
you can you can scale and you can
release new versions and rollback
quickly just through the magic of
kubernetes delete yamo so that's pretty
pretty neat today in the demos I'm going
to be showing I will be using the
hipster shop demo app you may have seen
this before and some of the other Google
the only reason that we use this demo
over others is that it we try to more
sort of simulate something you might
actually be running in production so
it's an e-commerce application with a
front end and a series of back-end
micro-services so traffic splitting
let's get into the demo shall we what I
will be showing again 90 percent of
traffic will be going to v1 10% to v2
all right so let's head over to our demo
here all right
can everyone see this okay do I need to
zoom in more all right so what just to
get a lay of the land here when I'm
showing on the right is just a set of
repeated curl commands to a version end
point of the front end so I currently
have one version of my front end
deployed to my kubernetes cluster this
is just plain old gke with plain old sto
installed on it and I am sending 100
requests to the front end service so
this is the kubernetes DNS name front
end dot service cluster local so what
I'm going to show here is creating a
destination rule that breaks the front
end into two pieces v1 and v2 and then I
will be splitting the traffic as I
showed there on the slides so what we'll
see on the right here hopefully is I'm
going to deploy the second version and
what we're gonna see right away is that
the default kubernetes round-robin load
balancing takes effect and what this
means it's just we're going to see 5050
just random selection between v1 and v2
and then I'll apply the rule and we will
watch 90% of traffic go to v2 so all
right we deploy v2 if I do a coups do
get pods here we can see that you saw
the old 503 there that the second
version of our front end is running if I
run this command again we've got front
end v2 running and then we're going to
apply the resources so apply the
destination rule and apply the traffic
splitting rule and what we'll see here
in real time is that about 90% of
traffic
is headed to v1 and we're doing a
Bluegreen on v2 again you in a real
production use case hopefully you're
using something like a continuous
deployment tool to do this but just for
demo purposes basic traffic splitting
with this to you let's do something a
little bit more more interesting here so
if we go back to the slides
perfect let's look at content based
routing so I mentioned a few minutes ago
that sto can't inspect requests and make
decisions based on those requests so
what I'm going to be showing is that you
can use sto to have a rule that looks at
the HTTP headers and routes to a
back-end based on the contents of that
header why would you want to do this
there would be potentially a lot of
reasons like traffic prioritization
doing building an a/b testing framework
on top of this teo would be an example
so what I'm going to show is that any
request that has a foo bar one header
just for demo purposes will go to front
and V 1 and all other requests will go
to front and V 2 all right so if we go
back to the terminal here I'm going to
reuse the setup I already had from from
the blue green demo and here's the rule
that allows you to do that content based
routing so again we're looking at a
virtual service sto CRD and rather than
doing just plain old splitting we're
going to do in a match on the header
with it with an exact match foo bar 1
and we're going to route all requests
that that fit that match to V 1 and then
we will route all other requests to V 2
notice the kind of the precedence that
is sort of implicit in this mo you know
they say you shouldn't build logic into
y amell's this virtual service does in
which we fall through so if we don't
have if we don't fit this match
condition we fall through to V 2 so here
on the right when I apply this rule and
it's a plain curl request with no
headers what do you think will happen
raise your hand if you think v1 it will
be only be 100% raise your hand if it
will be 100% v2 okay
okay just making sure you listen alright
so we're going to apply this resource
we're in place we're going to modify the
virtual service we already had right so
100 percent of requests going went to v2
why because we don't have that HTTP
request header Here I am in a pod and I
can curl the front end with that fubar
one header there version endpoint and we
will see v1 and just to show I'm not
faking here I can run this again and
again and again and we will see v1 run
it without the header and we will see me
too
so again demo purposes so I was showing
as best as I can it's kind of the the
things you can do on top of this to you
so if we go back to the slides here so
for all the subsequent demos in this
section I'm actually going to shift my
focus from things like load balancing to
building resilient microservices with
ISTE oh so in the following demo i will
be showing something called circuit
braking raise your hand if you've heard
of circuit braking yeah so this is a
very common sort of best practice for
micro services and for distributed
systems sto did not invent this in which
you wrap your services in a piece of
logic or circuit breaker such that if
you have multiple failing requests you
essentially you're applying back
pressure to avoid cascading failures and
it helps so what we're going to show is
if we have multiple concurrent requests
and and more than one fail we're going
to flip the circuit breaker or trip the
circuit breaker rather so that we fail
right away and we don't actually make
the full call to our front end and what
this yeah so what this helps you do is
if you wrap all of your services in this
logic you're building a more resilient
mesh and we all want that so what this
actual demo will show
I'm actually running a load generator
pod in my cluster and I will be sending
multiple concurrent requests to the
front-end and we're going to watch some
of them fail after we apply the rule so
I know it's kind of a demo but that's uh
let's head back to the terminal here so
I've got multiple clusters running I'm
actually going to go to a new cluster
for this demo and let's see here all
right I want to make sure I'm showing
this rule as best as I can okay so the
way you configure a circuit breaker in
Sto is with a destination rule and
you're like wait we've been doing
virtual services this whole time what's
a destination rule it's a little bit
strange
but basically a destination rule applies
to inbound traffic so what we're doing
is we're wrapping the front end service
in a destination rule such that and I
want to make sure I'm showing this as
best as I can such that if we have more
than one concurrent connection client
connection to the front end and more
than one of them is in pending state
we're going to start kicking out
subsequent client connections and these
are this is envoy logic so you can go
ahead and read about the way Envoy
implements outlier detection is CEO
builds on that doesn't really reinvent
the wheel at all the key thing to note
is that we are going to set that timeout
period for three minutes and I'm not
going to show the full three minutes but
yeah so that's circuit breaker so what
I'm going to do here is run multiple
concurrent requests into the front end
so in this example I'm going to do ten
concurrent requests 100 total requests
and we're going to watch all of these
paths hopefully and get to hundreds so
we can see here that all of the requests
to the front end pass which is good you
want more than ten clients to be able to
talk to your web front-end at once
ideally and we're going to apply the
destination rule
and we're going to run that command
again and what so what's happening is
envoy knows to kick a 503 error in the
case that the circuit breaker is tripped
so what we're going to see here in the
terminal on the right is a whole bunch
of five of threes hopefully right so
parsing on okay code 503 HTTP so that
came from envoy and you'll note so with
10 concurrent requests only 15% of them
actually went through to the front end
again in in production you would build
I'm kind of a more robust system around
testing this this is just kind of again
for demo purposes okay so that's circuit
breaker I've got one last demo in this
traffic rules section thank you for
bearing with me here if we go back to
the slides the last demo in this section
I'm going to show fault injection
so raise your hand if you've heard of
chaos testing and production yeah right
so the premise here is that traditional
unit integration smoke tests cannot
predict every failure case in your
microservices you would ideally like of
a system or a framework that is kind of
prodding at your mesh and trying to find
weak areas so that you can build up that
resilience right so the idea here is
that sto allows you to inject faults
into in one edge in your topology and so
what I mean by that is what we're going
to do in this demo is inject a HTTP 400
bad request error in a specific
connection between check out and product
catalog
notice we are not touching the requests
that are going from front end to product
catalog so that this is another example
of how SEO allows you to really
granularly choose sort of what parts of
traffic apply and what services again
yeah controlled controlled disruptions
into the mesh so let's let's go ahead
and demo that if we go back to the
terminal here switch over to a new
cluster all right okay so the way that
you do fall injection is with both a
destination rule and a virtual service
see here
right so let me show that the
destination rule all it does so again so
we're introducing a disruption between
checkout and product catalog so what
we're going to do is define a subset for
product catalog v1 and the virtual
service needs this to inject that fault
and so notice like with the content
based routing demo what we're doing is
this match condition but rather than
matching on the header we're matching on
the source workload so we're saying okay
only request from checkout should have
this 400 status code abort those
requests 100% of them everything else
fall through to normal behavior so
that's what we hope to see and the way
I'm going to demo this again just for
example purposes is by going into the
actual application into the front-end
and trying to do a checkout and it
hopefully will fail so let's see here
alright so we're gonna go into our
front-end oops that was not what we
wanted so let's see here here's our
external IP so here's the hipster shop
front-end and what we're going to do is
try to do a checkout so notice how we
injected the fall into product catalog
but we can still see the list of
products this is because again the
connections between front-end and
product catalog are still ok but if we
try to do a checkout place your order we
will see an error that says internal
failed to prepare order fail to get
product it's a 500 but internally it is
a 400 HTTP here and what we're going to
do is if I delete these rules and I try
to actually we do that checkout
transaction it'll work so again basic
fault injection you would usually apply
these sorts of resources in the context
of a larger more controlled experiment
um in production I would not advise
testing the resiliency of your
applications by applying these rules to
your production cluster maybe for
obvious reasons
so with that we end the first section
thanks for bearing with me if we go back
to the slides perfect alright so that
was kind of a whirlwind tour of sort of
east-west traffic routing and the key
here is to kind of give you a taste of
how you can build on top of the s2 api's
to do cool things yeah so in the last
two sections I'm going to cover ingress
and egress so traffic in first raise
your hand if you're running something
like nginx or a reverse proxy in front
of your services yeah right so inbound
and ingress traffic and to kubernetes or
into a data center is maybe nothing new
to anyone in this room the thing I would
like you to take away from this slide is
that if Steele has a very deliberate
model in which everything is a non-void
proxy so what
what is the value out of that it means
you can configure east-west traffic in
the same way you configure inbound and
outbound and with the same Y Emal's and
this becomes very powerful when you're
talking about things like M TLS and
traffic splitting and yeah so what I'm
going to show here is how exactly that's
working the way that sto ingress works
by default is that there is a default
ingress gateway a non-void proxy that is
running and is exposed internally
through an external IP on a Cobra 90s
cluster so that you can configure it to
punch a port in that ingress gateway to
allow traffic in and I've actually been
doing this this in the entire time so
I'm gonna show how that's been working
like how am i accessing the this web
front-end in my browser it's with this
exact set of resources my client my
laptop right here is going through the
ingress gateway configured via a gateway
Y Emmel going to an ingress virtual
service finally landing at the front and
back end the front-end front end packet
all right so here's the gateway mo that
allows us to configure that ingress
gateway right so we have
select your here that says I'm talking
about the default sto ingress gateway
you can help you can deploy your realm
but I'm basically punching a port port
80 in the default is do ingress gateway
and routing to any host I can figure it
with and in a lot of demos you'll see
this host wildcard star in production
you would be more specific about the
front-end so I'm just going to quickly
show those Hamill's in my terminal I'm
not gonna deploy anything new or special
see here alright perfect so let me show
you the actual ingress gateway pod
that's running so when you install ISTE
oh so these are all the sto control plan
components that are running in my
cluster and you'll notice this is do
ingress gateway pod this one out of one
so this is a single Envoy container that
is running that we will configure and we
can figure it like this through this
gateway resource these are the same
resources I just showed on the slides
and these are all applied to the cluster
I can do coups ETL gate gateway here it
is I can do a coup CTL get virtual
service I can actually show you that one
and we're saying for inbound hosts that
have made it to the virtual service
route to the backend running on port 80
which is where the kubernetes service is
running and what I can do from there is
get the sto kubernetes services get the
external IP of the ingress gateway and
this is how we get to the front-end so
in production you would be rep you would
be mapping I don't a well-known DNS name
to this IP and it's a stable IP that you
can use to back or to front rather
multiple services so if I go to this IP
I should be able to see the hipster shop
front end so that's a really quick
rundown of ingress there are ways to
secure Sara we can go back to the slides
actually thank you
so there are ways to configure that
ingress gateway to do things like
enforce mutual TLS
there is a wonderful demo out there that
shows securing the ingress gateway with
let's encrypt or any sort of assert
issuer that of your of your choice and
yeah I don't have time today to showcase
that but yeah I can I can find a way to
to link it it okay so that's ingress
traffic outbound traffic works in a
similar way in this do in that you can
choose to route outbound traffic through
an envoy proxy it should be said that in
sto 1.1 which was released a couple
weeks ago the egress gateway I believe
is now disabled by default not everyone
wants all traffic to go through an envoy
proxy as its leaving the mesh there are
very valid reasons why but here's the
basic model so when you want traffic so
I guess I should preface with this has
anyone ever installed SEO and all of a
sudden had things like your my sequel
connections just start to fail yeah
right so by default
SEO locks down outbound traffic this may
change in the future but right now if
you've encountered this problem that is
why you need a yeah Mille you need a
service entry that says yes it's okay
for my traffic to go to my sequel and
this is where it is think of a service
entry as a piece of inventory of a well
known hostname that you are allowing
outbound traffic to and you add one of
these for anything that needs your in
mesh services need to access outside so
this would be like an API like the
Google GCE api's and when you add one of
these resources by default it goes
directly to that external service from
the service services envoy proxy what I
want to show as kind of my my final demo
here is a way to secure do do this do
egress traffic more securely so imagine
that you have a situation in which you
want to really carefully monitor any
traffic that is leaving your environment
so say you're running sto on Prem in a
specific region and you want to make
sure that you can enforce or at least
inspect outbound traffic
so what you can do is input a non-void
proxy in between your in mesh service
and your external service to do exactly
that so what I'm going to show in this
demo is I'm going to configure the
egress gateway in sto to to look at all
traffic to this ie you bank endpoint why
would you want to do this there's
another really good reason why which is
start it I think it's an increasing best
practice to think of in mesh services
same way as you would out of mesh
services and what I mean that this is
just because something is running in
your cluster does not mean you can
necessarily trust it right kubernetes
has service accounts in it we have our
back-end we have all these systems in
place but that doesn't mean that a
malicious service can't make its way
into your cluster with for example a
docker image with it's kind of an
erroneous tag so that is why I think
this demo is is somewhat relevant so
what I'm going to be showing here is
that in our demo app one of our backends
talks to a Bank API to get exchange
rates and we're going to put an egress
gateway in between the currency service
and the API to look at outbound traffic
I'm not going to show this in this demo
but what you could do with this gateway
is configure it just as we did all the
way up until now with rules such as
enforce MPLS but to the the EU Bank
endpoint so with that I will do this
final demo back in my terminal oops
all right
perfect let's get on the right cluster
here awesome so let's look at the
resources that allow us to do exactly
this so right now right now I just have
my plane demo app deployed no no fancy
rules no traffic is not going through a
[ __ ] and what I want to show just to
prove it's working is to actually get
the really spammy logs of this egress
gateway I'm actually yeah sure I
apologize if this hurts anyone's eyes
alright so what we're gonna hopefully
see and I was running this a little bit
earlier so sorry for the spoiler alert
but we're going to watch requests go
through the egress gateway via the logs
once I enable these rules what rules am
I about to enable these so the way that
you would get this demo working is you
would configure the egress gateway which
is already running because I'm running a
slightly dated version of this deal you
would configure this egress gateway to
route traffic to the external endpoint
and then from there you would add
additional resources the first would be
ensure that traffic goes through this
secure gateway by specifying route rules
just as we have been throughout this
demo and sorry that they're a little bit
dense here so it's I know a lot to kind
of grep visually and then we would
define a destination rule that again is
forcing traffic to go instead of from
currency service directly to the EU bank
endpoint we are using route rules to
funnel that traffic through the egress
gateway and so what we will hopefully
see in the egress gateway logs is we
will see a warm up log that says ok I'm
the egress gateway and I know that I
should I can be talking to the Eubank
API and then we will see the actual
request go through once I try to do a
currency conversion
all right so let's do apply the
resources and we can see here in the
egress gateway logs it's kind of hard to
see but we have this warming cluster
outbound ACB which is the European
Central Bank complete so the Envoy has
been configured with the rules that
needs and then if we go into the front
end and we just try to like do a do a
refresh here so it's a bit slow we may
or may not have some throttling issues
with this API as we demo it repeatedly
all right and we try to do a currency
conversion here what we'll hopefully see
when we go back to the logs is that a
request went through the egress gateway
all right sorry for all those uh
telemetry errors but yeah so we see
these all these HTTP GET requests to
that API so yeah so that's that's kind
of securing egress traffic again with
with demos it can be kind of tough to
show exactly how you would bring this
into your own environments but I hope it
at least could kind of gives you a taste
so with that I'm gonna go back to the
slides and wrap up thank you so much for
bearing with me I know it's like a lot
of demos and a lot of yeah mole to stare
at all right back to the slides closing
thoughts I want to stress that SCO 1.1
was released a couple of weeks ago super
exciting it was the result of a ton of
hard work in the community not just by
Google but by many other organizations
and individuals to help improve SEO
performance and scalability so Wanda was
not too long ago and now we're in 1.1
what this means is that sto is still a
relatively young technology some things
are changing and it is on the open right
it's open source but what I want to I
guess stress is that the these api's are
the building blocks from which you build
other things so SEO might have internal
control playing changes in the coming
months year the hope is that these API
objects become the things that your
organization's build on to
do cool stuff so that's 1.1 what are
some best practices for bringing a CEO
into production this is just my two
cents
it would be to start somewhat slow pick
the one feature that you really want to
bring to your environment or try out if
you have kind of a sandbox cluster so
this could be something like a Bluegreen
deployment this could be enabling M TLS
which I didn't even cover in this talk
and learn the CR D so like learn the
virtual service for that feature and it
becomes easier after that to do other
things there is a somewhat steep
learning curve that I know I encountered
myself so I would stress that and from
there kind of gather the toolkit that
helps you figure out when things go
wrong
so there's awesome open-source tools
that do service graphs okey Ali is one
example and yeah there's a command-line
tool called sto CTL if you've never
encountered that it's on the docs it can
do things like validate resources check
if M TLS is working look at the proxy
status file via the Envoy api's it can
do a ton of cool stuff and then yeah
from there work your way up it's
definitely a journey similar perhaps to
adopting kubernetes not trying to say
that it's easy because it's a it's a bit
of a road and this talk did not even I
don't think scratches really the surface
of what SEO can do we API management is
one example and user authentication with
tokens our back unified policies across
services which services can access which
doing custom telemetry forwarding to
whether to the sink of your choice
Prometheus kevanna hybrid environments
right mesh expansion two VMs multiple
kubernetes clusters I mean it's do is I
think a massive piece of technology that
can do a whole bunch of really cool
stuff and if this is interesting for you
yeah I would encourage you to check out
the other talks that I'll be showing on
the screen in a few moments I wanted to
give a quick call out to anthos which
was announced yesterday which is Google
sort of hybrid multi cloud offering and
I want to maybe clarify
Steele plays a key role in anthos the
way is steel plays a key role is via the
api's so all the resources I've been
showing throughout this talk which will
serve its gateway destination rule all
of those can be used to configure your
mesh and anthos the control plane in
anthos is Google managed so what I
showed was using open source sto pilot
to actually configure the Envoy proxies
today we announced traffic director
which is the Google managed pilot is a
helpful way to think about it but it
works this kind of the same way as pilot
and that it uses the Envoy xes api's to
to configure the proxies so I hope that
clarifies the things if you're if you're
a kind of a bit confused about how all
the pieces fit together I want to also
say that there this is not the end there
are multiple other SCO talks this week
at next a quick call out that I'm giving
another talk tomorrow morning at 9 a.m.
in the AMC metrion debugging sto and
it's almost entirely demos so if this
was not enough for you and you want a
whole nother hour of this and your week
you can join us tomorrow morning
one final call-out that we hear here at
Google we are conducting some user
studies for folks who are either not
using SEO or are currently trying to use
this do and if you would like to join
these user studies and to provide
feedback in any way go to the forum here
all right so we are at 9 minutes I would
love to answer some live questions in
the remaining time I do want to say that
if I'm not able to answer your question
right now I'm happy to talk after I will
be around outside the room I'm not I
guess in all-knowing sto guru although I
really wish I was
so with that anyone who wants to ask a
question can just line up at those mics
right down the middle and I will try to
answer as best as I can thank you
[Applause]
[Music]